croco mom the theory that should not be
anything else but a bunch of people
trolling one-piece fans
i mean come on crocodile used to be a
woman that had a kid with dragon and
that kid is luffy the protagonist that
got impaled by sad crocodile
yeah no this is totally a thing what's
up amanu and in case you aren't familiar
with it yet here's the pitch you will
usually hear from people who support
this theory the idea that crocodile
might be female basically emerged
together with the release of the chapter
back in
2009 well the idea that he might be
luffy's mother seems to be from sometime
in 2011. although the original post that
is referenced a lot over the internet
does not exist anymore for some reason
basically the idea is based on a single
interaction during the impul down arc a
single line of dialogue between ivankov
one of the leading members of the
revolutionary army and sir crocodile the
former warlords that terrorized alabasta
and who was ultimately taken down by
luffy in this scene here ivankov
basically blackmailed crocodile into
helping them by threatening to reveal
his weakness a secret death that
crocodile owes to ivankov for something
he was given as oda confirms later on on
crocodile's weaver cards
and since ivankov's most unique power
has been specifically shown to be
changing people's bodies as far as
switching genders the theory is that
crocodile used to be a woman luffy's mom
to be precise that then was turned into
a man by ivankov and boy did i have a
very emotional rollercoaster like
personal journey with this theory
basically ever since this theory was
first brought to my attention years ago
it hasn't gone away ever since
ever and so i practically went through
all five stages of grief here first
denial when i first heard about this
idea my reaction was basically
this isn't real someone's definitely
trolling these poor people then anger
once i realized that people were taking
this seriously and actually talking
about whether it was possible or not i
was genuinely pissed that people were
debating this seriously when there were
so many other great things to talk about
with one piece for example i don't know
how about this 30 minute ecstatic
rambling session about where the one
piece is
stage three bargaining this is when i
basically started to try and debate
people who believed in this theory and
try to explain to them why it was a
stupid idea and why they were wrong so
so wrong i guess i don't have to tell
you that those attempts mostly failed so
i
entered stage four depression that was
actually quite recently i just didn't
want to talk about the crocomom theory
anymore at all i thought there were so
much more interesting ideas out there
that deserved so much more attention and
so i just tried to push the idea out of
my head however everything changed a
couple of weeks ago when i started
working on my most recent video on
luffy's mom i had basically found out
that mothers or to be precise their
complete and utter absence from one
piece plays an incredibly important and
central role to the story and of course
i also wanted to discuss a couple of
ideas for who luffy's mom could possibly
be and
do you know that feeling when you turn
around and suddenly someone is just
standing there that was exactly what it
felt like when the croco mom theory
jumped right at me once i started to
work on this laughing in my face
and at that point i had enough of this
no more hiding it was time to switch
gears completely and go into the
offensive i decided to take this stupid
theory dismantle it to its core and
prove to the world once and for all that
there was no way
no way that crocodile is luffy's mom and
so after sleepless nights of vigorous
work i finally finally managed to find
the answer to this mystery that had
tormented me for years
yeah crocodile is luffy's mom
so it looks like i've ended up in stage
five now acceptance but allow me to
guide you through my thought process
here and what i actually found because
as it turns out there is a lot more
evidence in the story to support this
theory than i originally could have ever
anticipated i'm really curious and not
sure if the person who first came up
with this idea had difficulties
expressing how good his theory actually
was or if it was just a super stupid
idea that then turned out to have a lot
more depth to it by sheer accidents to
be honest a lot of the follow-up
theories for croco mom have been pretty
damn bad however i have distilled the
best parts of everything i could find
and then added in my own thoughts to
this as well and so to begin with i want
to start with the idea that crocodile is
a woman and then move on to him being
luffy's mom because let's be real those
two are very different levels of crazy
that apparently i'm now a part of oh and
also
please just ignore my use of pronouns in
this video please i'll really try my
best but it's probably gonna be a mess
we've already talked about the most
fundamental thing to this entire theory
with ivankov there is actually a power
in one piece that is able to change
genders which is how the entire theory
started in the first place
and the fact that this was all shown so
closely to the encounter with crocodile
definitely helps the credibility of
these two being connected plus ivankov
keeps calling him croco boy in what i
think is a bit of a mocking way now it
could just be that ivankov wants to take
away from his manliness but maybe it's
also supposed to put more attention on
exactly that aspect of his character now
one thing that i think is important to
consider is oda's inspiration for the
warlords here not only do all of the
original shichibukai have an animal
theme but the group as a whole was
inspired by the video game romancing
saga 2 that was released in japan back
in
1993 which is older than i am wow and
each of the warlords shares the
characteristics with one of the heroes
of this game for example there's rock
bouquet i think is how you pronounce
that the only female of the seven who
controls all the men in the jungle
villages with her charm which then of
course became boa hancock
a puppeteer demon who rules over his own
little realm with his own slaves and
whose special technique marionettes
allows him to manipulate all party
members which of course is the
inspiration for buggy
the character that is important for us
here is called wagners who has enslaved
an entire country and wants to find an
ancient weapon to control the world
now what is really interesting about
wagner's is that while he is male
everything about him looks and feels
female now the fastest way to disprove
the idea that crocodile is female would
be by looking at his past clearly
showing him to be a guy and we actually
do have two instances of crocodile
before the current timeline one of them
is this sketch made by oda of all the
warlords as children in case you're
wondering crocodile is here a kid who
might be either a boy or a girl and
resembles hancock most of all the others
the second time is during roger's
execution however crocodile is only
shown from behind here what we can see
is a fur coat long purple hair an
earring and a cigar both in the anime
and the manga and since oda has already
done us the favor and drawn the opposite
sex of each of the seven warlords we can
say that this panel of crocodile from
behind would fit with either the male or
the female version of him and as you
know oda sometimes like to hide and hint
at things in the color spreads and cover
pages and as it happens this is the
official cover and title of chapter 938
now one thing i know will stand out to
you by now because it definitely did to
me is that everything surrounding
crocodile is weirdly connected to gender
ideas all the code names of his agents
are mr and mrs his name isn't just
desert king crocodile no it's desert
king sir crocodile like oda going oh
yeah in case you haven't realized that
this man is really madly by the way no
really he's he's a sir and mr zero croco
boy i was actually considering calling
him sir testosterone that's how manly he
is and then there was the introduction
of mr tubonclay one of my favorite
characters by the way i feel like that
dude actually deserves an entire video
of his own misery
[Music]
and the fact that this man is part of
crocodile's agency is just a pure
treasure trove of hints this man of
man's has someone in his strictly
gendered organization who plays both the
male and female part of his double agent
theme he's mister 2 a number and also
mrs bonclay two festival holidays in
japan not only is bon clay the first of
the discriminated okama introduced in
the story that crocodile seems to
tolerate and integrate just fine into
his plans but he also has the ability to
change faces from man to woman to man
becoming someone completely different
every
[Music]
time isn't hinting at something
but there's even more to this bon clay
as one of the okama comes from okama
island an island that not only gives us
a connection between ivankov and
crocodile but more importantly between
crocodile and dragon most of the okama
are part of the revolutionary army whose
leader is none other than dragon luffy's
father so all of this so far has mostly
served as my argument that crocodile
used to be a woman which actually has
surprisingly much support in large parts
of the fandom however and i totally
understand why saying that crocodile was
a woman and that crocodile is luffy's
mother are two very
very different cups of tea more like a
cup of tea and a cup of coffee and still
i believe that both of these things are
true here's why by the way in case
you're enjoying theories like these and
want to delve deeper into the endless
deep and hopefully fascinating lore of
one piece with me every single week i'd
love for you to consider subscribing to
my channel now there are a couple of
really big arguments that seem to bury
the crocomom idea fairly quickly which i
know well because i used the very same
argument quite a lot back in the day
first if crocodile was actually luffy's
mom why didn't he recognize him well
because he hadn't seen luffy since he
was a baby okay but then why didn't
crocodile recognize his last name if he
had a kid with dragon to which i would
say
for the same reason no one else knew
that luffy was related to dragon or that
garp was related to dragon
come on
[Music]
dragon simply never shared his last name
until it was revealed publicly during
the war
i mean look even ivankov didn't
recognize luffy's last name now if luffy
were actually crocodile's child wouldn't
they have some similarities well they do
both of them have the undying loyalty of
their crews with dust bones still
following crocodile even after impelled
down the zorro to baroque works luffy in
a way crocodile just like modia had his
dreams crushed at some point by
whitebeard basically giving us a version
of luffy that had given up on his dreams
which is then accentuated by how he
constantly lectures luffy during their
first two encounters basically like a
parents plus we have this mafia special
here where luffy literally looks like
crocodile and there's also this great
comic of luffy turning into crocodile
though admittedly i don't think that's
canon i think that's just fan art but
still so at least now we know that
crocodile did not know that luffy was
dragon's child and so he has an excuse
for impaling and mortally wounding his
potential kids but that doesn't prove
anything yet no because for that we
actually have to look at marine ford and
specifically crocodile's action during
marine ford after it was revealed that
luffy was dragon's son because
interestingly enough after his initial
attempt to attack whitebeard he then
actually did a few things that seemed
extremely out of character because he
went out of his way and endangered
himself without really needing to for
luffy's sake and also keep in mind that
we never got to actually see his
reaction to the luffy dragon reveal just
as we got no reaction of his to rogers
execution so here's all the out of
character stuff he suddenly started
doing
number one he stopped ace's execution
with the excuse that he didn't want
sengoku to have the pleasure of victory
which if you ask me is a big pile of
poop as an argument now some people will
tell you it's because luffy inspired him
like luffy does with many others but
what exactly has luffy done in
marineford he didn't do an impul down or
even back in alabasta
nothing which then would imply that
crocodile would have had an entire
change of heart for no apparent reason
whatsoever and completely off-screen
which is not very oda-like if i dare say
so then he and does bones hold off
mihawk to protect luffy
[Music]
so just so you understand suddenly
crocodile orders his only remaining
loyal man to protect the life of the
person that ruined his life and his
plans and put him in prison i mean yeah
he may refrain from killing luffy
because of ivanka of being there but he
surely wouldn't have gone out of his way
to send his best man off for him and
then when crocodile jumps in himself
when mihawk questions why he protected
luffy crocodile's only response is this
again why should he suddenly be in a bad
mood well maybe because he just found
out he once stabbed his own child in the
gut and left him to die but if those
weren't weird enough yet he does the
unthinkable and faces off with akainu
probably the strongest person in the
entire war
and so i think that the fact that as
luffy is lying there unconscious and
weak with jimbei slumped over him akainu
about to deliver the final blow
crocodile coming out of nowhere to save
him and safely transport into law is
once again so telling i mean this is a
man that shouldn't have been on luffy's
side for so many reasons that has left
people behind for being useless or too
weak
now seemingly out of nowhere goes full
zorro mode for luffy willing to
sacrifice himself for him
there were plenty plenty of other
characters that could have essentially
done the same exact thing but oda chose
to have crocodile duets who then has
this epic shot here as well standing
side by side with all of whitebeard's
commanders his sworn enemies just like a
protective mother that would sacrifice
anything for her child because crocodile
now knows that luffy is his son mothers
in one piece play an incredibly
important role and there are also a few
other possibilities for who luffy's mom
might be make sure to check out that
video here if you haven't seen it yet
because it's right here it is